[Musica]
buonasera cari amici di foggia sono
molto contenta di essere tra voi vi
racconterò le mie scintille io sono un
chimico un chimico organi con una vita
del chimico ci sono tante scintille
nella mia vita ho anche viaggiato tanto
perché essere creativi spesso bisogna
spostarsi e quindi molto rapidamente
visto che il collega presentatore e
medico ha fatto un breve riassunto io
sono nato a venezia sono cresciuta a
firenze ho studiato ho fatto
l'università di chimiche a genova e poi
sono migrata nel mondo sono stato a
monaco di baviera
da lì l'istituto nazionale della sanità
a washington di sì poi sono tornata in
italia o dove ho lavorato a genova
reggio emilia ea milano dove sono in
bicocca
quando è nata lì vi racconterò un po
diciamo la storia della mia vita di
ricerca quando è nata l'ispirazione la
scintilla di fare la ricercatrice in
campo diciamo delle scienze naturali è
nata a venezia dove andavo sempre
diciamo in spiaggia un area
dell'adriatico come in puglia
e se voi avete più scelta e vi sono
interessata un po a granchi pesci alghe
mi piaceva l'idea di studiare un po la
biologia dietro quello che che vedevo
e a venezia ho sempre passato
molto tempo dalla mia vita anche girando
tutte le estati e qui una fotografia in
cui seguiamo il rito dello spritz io mi
sono interessata anche di studiare un po
le bevande con mia mamma che è mancato a
un paio di settimane fa pertanto ero
quasi in deciso di venire a fare il ted
ma invece l'idea di stare insieme in
allegria mi hanno fatto molto piacere
e questo è il lido di venezia dove è
nata la prima intilla in tempi odierni e
quindi ho deciso di fare la scienziata
questo così una foto un po patinata del
del mito del laboratorio noi sentiamo
sempre parlare aveva sentito parlare
prima di tutte le cose belle che si
fanno nella scienza di quanto si scopre
di come linfoot uro e brillante di come
inventiamo cose nuove di come curiamo le
malattie
naturalmente l'inizio è stato un po
complesso è stato un po complesso per
esempio perchè come avete visto una
prima foto ero
giovane ragazza un po po po freak
a quei tempi negli anni 70 con
cappelloni chitarra e tutti i miei amici
erano abbastanza filosofici e quindi al
momento di varare la tesi facevano la
tesi non so su leopardi o la tesi su
michelangelo la tesi su omero e io
facevo la tesi sull'alcol easy delle di
arin su fu di mili
ma chi esce con una ragazza così di che
si parlava io come potevo spiegare già
secondo voi nessuno lo sa ripetere
l'alcol easy delle diarie su frw di mini
perfino a mio papà non ne voleva sapere
negli argomento di tesi e questo fu
infatti la prima pubblicazione della mia
carriera scientifica sulla gazzetta
chimica italiana e le scintille per me
sono nate proprio nel laboratorio perché
io dovevo sintetizzare questa molecola è
stata la prima molecola che ho inventato
green sulphur divide e si doveva mettere
insieme altre due molecole più piccole
fare un colorante un colorante che si
prevedeva essere giallo rancio e nella
tesi io dovevo capire come metterla
insieme sarà un po come le ricette di
cucina soprattutto a quei tempi adesso
la chimica un pochino più diciamo
sofisticata high throughput allora era
abbastanza sul bancone e devo mettere
insieme due sostanze diverse combinarle
e creare questa molecola che non veniva
mai passavano i mesi e non riuscivo a
sintetizzarla allora mi sono messa a
studiare il tedesco perché i tempi
a quei tempi i libri di ricette di
cucina della chimica erano in tedesco
perché la chimica organica era stata
inventata in germania e c'era solo il
capo del laboratorio che sapeva il
tedesco e quindi notte tempo
andavo a sfogliare questi libri di
cucina e ho pensato ho trovato l'idea
che ci volesse un catalizzatore diverso
catalizzatore e quello che abbassa
praticamente l'energia di legame e
quindi favorisce una reazione e ho
deciso di usare l'alluminio metallico
che non è proprio quello delle pentole
di alluminio e metallo puro 15 avevo
questo palloncino di
versione ho buttato dentro le mie due
sostanze e poi ho fatto lasciato cadere
il foglietto di alluminio metallico e si
ho inventato la molecola infatti esploso
tutto radicamente è venuta fuori questa
bella molecola gialla che ha dipinto
soffitto pareti tutto quanto per cui il
mio professore molto contento che
avevamo la pubblicazione però abbiamo
dovuto anche ridipingere il laboratorio
da capo a piedi e questa è stata la
prima parte dopodiché per poterla
purificare si usano i solventi e perché
le molecole organiche spesso non sono
solo le nell'acqua e quindi ho pensato
quale il solvente migliore e ho scelto
il benzene e benzene sono un po come
benzina e di solito come vedete in
questo apparecchio quando si scalda un
solvente si fa anche ricadere si
raffredda con l'acqua e riscende io
invece per fare presto mi sono
dimenticata quel pezzo di attrezzatura
quindi ho scaldato la mia sostanza con
il benzene e naturalmente i vapori hanno
preso fuoco e quindi ha dato fuoco al
laboratorio e allora sono andata di
corsa a cercare il mio professore al mio
professore era un professore bolognese
che amava molto la cucina era circa 120
chili era un ragionamento e corpulento e
socio and esami è usata da lui e gli ho
detto
professore il professore albini non vedi
che sto facendo gli esami professoressa
andando a fuoco in laboratorio ed
improvvisamente un'agilità pazzesca ha
fatto un balzo felino arrivato il
laboratorio afferra l'estintore perché
tutti facciamo movimento corso a
sicurezza spruzza sul fuoco ma il
sentore rivolto verso di sé e quindi
diventa una specie di pupazzetto di neve
completamente bianco rotondo bianco e io
comincio a ridere mentre il laboratorio
bruciava dopo di che arrivano altri
spengono al fuoco
però mi hanno detto alvini tu sei un
grande e chimico e appena sintetizzata
una molecola però tutto sommato se fai
qualcosa di più tranquillo sarebbe
meglio per tutti noi
allora ho scelto che sarei passata a
studiare il dna che forse faceva meno
danni che a sintetizzarne le mie proprie
molecole
e quindi sono andata in germania a
studiare biochimica forte del mio 110 e
lode che nonostante le scintille
numerose scintille provocate al mio
laboratorio avevo preso con la mia
sintesi e sono andato appunto in
germania e poi negli stati uniti e ho
messo su dei team che lavoravano di
sulla biologia molecolare e qui
naturalmente abbiamo fatto altre
scintille perché ho incontrato mio
marito che un altro scienziato perché
come dicevo nessuna persona normale può
sposare uno scienziato che si occupa di
robe impronunciabili se non
probabilmente un collega e quindi questo
signore americano che i capelli rossi
poi ha fatto un po di scintille con me
abbiamo fatto anche due bambini come
prodotti di queste scintille post
laboratorio e perché questo o no i 22
scintillone maschio femmina thomas
silvio adesso sono grandi qui vogliamo
il te perché mi sono occupata anche di
sostanze nelle bevande ma ho insistito
con i nomi difficili per cui anche
qualche anno fa abbiamo trovato dei
nuovi inibitori possibilmente ricerca
oncologica n o isopropyl su formigue
based cross amat
anche qui non abbiamo tanto bene fa
raccontare agli amici durante una festa
di sera quindi abbiamo cercato di
rendere le cose più divulgative e negli
stati uniti il mio marito mi ha anche
lui ha aiutato ad alcuni disastri ad
esempio una volta che stavo cercando di
isolare il clone di un dna ed era tutto
separato in una specie di gelatina
perché usiamo questi gel di haga rose
per separare il dna
ovviamente esco di corsa dal laboratorio
mi cade tutto per terra questa gelatina
si spappola sul pavimento
il mio marito mi dice posso aiuta a
futuro marito posso aiutarti in qualche
modo guarda ho distrutto l'esperimento
fa no ma no stai tranquilla prende tutti
i pezzettini di gelatina pazientemente
veri mette assieme ed ecco che abbiamo
trovato al clone del dna di una proteina
importante per il retinoblastoma e da lì
appunto tra amicizia e amore
ci sono vari modi di essere romantici
ecco anche salvando gli esperimenti
ho avuto la fortuna di conoscere persone
importanti ricerche oncologiche a qui
sono con umberto veronesi e dagli spread
che farei ricerca sullo spritz e poi
dopo non sembra che sicuro il cancro
colo spritz però essendo stata in
germania mi sono dedicata alla birra e
dalla birra abbiamo ricavato una nuova
molecola che si chiama xantumolo è
praticamente un antiossidante un
antinfiammatorio forse preventivo dei
tumori che si ricava dal luppolo e
questo perché luppolo è un grande e
disinfettante per la birra stessa se
vuoi trasportate la birra dall'india per
fare l'ipia per esempio è perché il
luppolo la protegge dalle infezioni e
quindi abbiamo fatto questa sintesi del
lupo la loro quando mi sono iniziati a
occuparmi di chimica degli alimenti
hanno iniziato a invitarmi queste
trasmissioni televisive a parlare delle
robe più strane
questa è una trasmissione natalizia di
elizier tutta salute eccetera
e siccome la diciamo nella vita ci sono
tante cose divertenti da raccontare come
avete sentito mi sono data anche a
scrivere romanzi uno di il primo si
chiama un clone in valigia questo clone
era praticamente il dna che serviva per
produrre una proteina della retina come
vi dicevo che è quella che abbiamo
raccolto sul pavimento con mio marito
quando si era distrutta
ciò nonostante è sopravvissuto al
pavimento ed è diventata un composto
importante e poi tra gli altri gialli
sto muovendo fatto un po di giallistica
come una piccola casa editrice che
comunque rende abbastanza bene che si
chiama frilli è arrivata alla folla
offerta da mondatori di fare
segretissimo prima avete sentito lo
scienziato e sentiva indiana jones io
che lo vedrete faccio la scherma facevo
un molecole esplosive il laboratorio un
segretissimo ho detto con un po di
chirurgia plastica potrei fare allara
croft e quindi a cosa mi è piaciuta
volto e qui è arrivata all'altra
scintilla che scrivo questo romanzo
romanzo scrivo tutti i romanzi si
svolgono in laboratorio sono un po
noiosa chiama mia vita il laboratorio
penn di tutti i miei gialli hanno una
base al laboratorio e questo era
praticamente uno scienziato americano
che invece di riscrivere il dna dei
dinosauri riscriveva il dna di un
bambino di una nobile famiglia araba e
andavo a farlo naturalmente in egitto
questo qualche anno fa e consegno questo
manoscritto alla mondadori la quale il
melo restituisci dicendo il libro bello
ci piace il plot però ci sono troppi
pochi morti e troppe poche scene di
sesso scusi come non ho capito eh sì il
segretissimo a una formula c'è solo
nella chimica
bisogna che muoiono un certo numero di
persone e ogni 50 pagine si deve fare
l'amore in qualche modo naturalmente
interessante la scritta lo vuoi perché
io faccio la scienziata non ognuno deve
avere il suo stile
e allora mi sono messa lì bottiglia di
vino scrivi queste cose se consultiamo
ci facciamo delle prove eccetera
eccetera
alla fine
alla fine è andata bene è stato
pubblicato però io ho detto scusate però
non potete io faccio la professoressa
vado dai miei studenti vado tutta per
benino che mi occhialini non potete
pubblicare il segretissimo co ste cose
qua con scritto adriana albini cambia
temi nome allora mi hanno messo adrian
home adriana white vuol dire albini
praticamente quindi oppure un romanzo
come adrian white e quella scintilla che
la terza s
dopo la scrittura quella della scherma
io pratico uno sport per anziani perché
ovviamente non abbiamo più l'età quella
della prima foto che avevo 17 anni e
quindi facciamo la scherma master a dei
veterani e anche nella scherma si
accende la scintilla perché quando
toccate l'avversario si accende la
lampadina e c'è un piccolo pulsantino
che faccende la lampadina
naturalmente ci affrontiamo tra noi
anziani ci vediamo di santa ragione e
sono riuscita forza di allenarmi a
prendere l'argento euro europeo nel
nel 2015 mi vedete sul sul podio e
quest'anno il bronzo mondiale nei
veterani naturalmente qui con altri con
altri altrettanto anziani ma comunque
combattenti
ci sono degli ex olimpionici queste
adriano e nella squadra azzurra e colgo
l'occasione per fare un piccolo cameo
per salutare le mie amiche e
schermitrici di foggia
io vengo foggia tutti gli anni a
disputare il campionato master
queste sono le ragazze che hanno vinto
l'oro ai mondiali di quest'anno nella
gara a squadre di sciabola e stasera
fanno una una festa della scherma e ci
trasformiamo nella san charaki mia
chimiche anche questa vedete passiamo da
questa cosa brucia ma natalie della gara
di scherma mondiale alla serata sempre
con le amiche foggiane dove eravamo
andati al e naturalmente anche qui c'è
la l'episodio per cui per la qualifica
alla mancata scintilla per la qualifica
ai mondiali
affronto una amica e avversaria molto
forte che parla di saletto vincevo più o
meno del 4 pari vincevo sempre io quindi
colpo finale una botta pazzesca
penso di aver vinto invece se scende
l'altra luce e allora delusissima scendo
dalla pedana vado dall'armiere guardo la
squadra ma tutto posto i fili nessun
problema lordo d'allarme e dico io sono
sicura di aver toccato questo succede
lui guarda fa ma albini non c'è la punta
in questa spada come potevi toccare ecco
calcolando la distrazione
io andato a combattere con una arma non
elettrificata quindi altro che
scintillano in quel caso scintilluni
proprio quindi bisogna fare attenzione
con tutto e infine devo dire che
nell'esperienza civilizzante la scherma
conosciuto persone anche molto carina e
molto speciali e quindi diciamo voglio
finire con una foto con bebe vio che voi
conoscete come olimpionica e mondiale
della scherma paralimpica appena vinto
un'altra medaglia a cui siamo sempre al
galà dei mondiali di scherma per anziani
a quali vedete nel nello sfondo ci sono
da con i capelli bianchi e questo
diciamo a chiacchierata per raccontare
che tra disastri esplosioni disguidi
varie pasticci la scintilla vince sempre
quindi siate persistenti alla fine
nonostante su disastri che ho fatto ho
fatto una ragionevole carriera però
contanti appunto anche piccoli
inconvenienti e soprattutto anche con la
scintilla si superano i problemi di ogni
tipo anche quelli della salute e quindi
spero di avervi raccontato un po e poi
se volete dopo vi parlo anche di cose
più serie sui nostri studi di quello che
è stata un'avventura scintillante nella
ricerca grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]